this reminded me of um the thing that
you and and Jack Dorsey uh jokingly had
for a while the discussion about banning
uh Donald Trump from Twitter
um but does any of it bother you now
that Twitter files came out
that I mean this has to do with sort of
the hunter laptop Hunter byton laptop
story
does it bother you that there could be a
collection of people that make decisions
about who to Banner not and then
that could be susceptible to bias and to
ideological influence well I I think
it always will be or you know in the
absence of perfect AI it always will be
and this becomes relevant with AI as
well yeah because yeah here's some
censorship on AI happening yeah and it's
an interesting question there as well I
don't think Twitter is important as
people think it is right and and I I
used to think it was more important when
I was on it and now that I'm off of it I
think it's it's uh
I mean first let me say it's just a an
unambiguously good thing in my
experience to delete your Twitter
account right it's like it is just even
the good parts of Twitter that I miss
were bad in the aggregate in the the
degree to which it was fragmenting my
attention the degree to which my life
was getting doled out to me in
periods between those moments where I
checked Twitter right and had my
attention diverted and I was you know I
was not a a crazy Twitter addict I mean
I was a I was probably a pretty normal
user I mean I was not someone who was
tweeting multiple times a day or even
every day right I probably
I think I probably averaged
something like one tweet a day I think I
average but in reality it was like you
know there'd be like four tweets one day
and then I wouldn't tweet for you know
the better part of a week
and but I was looking
a lot because it was my news feed I was
just following you know 200 very smart
people and I just wanted to see what
they were paying attention to and they
would recommend articles and I would
read those articles and and then when I
would read an article then I would that
I would thought I should signal boost I
would tweet and so all of that seemed
good and you know like that's all
separable from all of the odious
[__] that came back at me in
response to this largely in response to
this Hunter Biden thing
um
but even the good stuff
has a downside and and it and it comes
at just this point of your phone is this
Perpetual stimulus of
um
which is intrinsically fragmenting of
time and attention and now my phone is
is much less of a presence in my life
and it's it's not that I don't check
slack or check email I mean you know I
use it to work but
um
my sense of just what the world is and
my sense of my place in the world the
sense of where I exist as a person
has changed a lot by deleting my Twitter
account I mean I had it and it's just
it's um and the things that I think I
mean we all know this phenomenon because
we say of someone that person is too
online right like what does it mean to
be too online
and where do you draw the that that
boundary you know where how do you know
what constitutes being too online well
and sometimes just be I think being on
on social media at all is to be too
online I mean get given what it does to
given the kinds of information it it um
signal boosts and given the um
given the impulse it Kindles in each of
us to reach out to our audience
in at in specific moments and in
specific ways right it's like
there there are lots of moments now
where I have an opinion about something
but there's nothing for me to do with
that opinion right like there's no
Twitter right so like there's lots of
things that I would have tweeted in the
last months
that are not the kind of thing I'm going
to do a podcast about I'm not going to
roll out 10 minutes on that topic on my
podcast I'm not going to take the time
to really think about it but had I been
on Twitter I would have reacted to this
thing in the news or this thing that
some somebody did right what do you do
with that thought no I just let go of it
like chocolate ice cream is the most
delicious thing yeah it's usually not
that sort of thing but it's it's just
but then you look at the kinds of
problems people create for themselves
you look at the life deranging and
reputation destroying things that people
do
and I look at the things that that have
the analogous things that have happened
to me I mean the things that have really
bent my life around professionally over
the past you know decade
so much of it is Twitter I mean it
honestly in my case almost a hundred
percent of it was Twitter the
controversies I would get into the
things I would think I would have to
respond to in a pot like I would release
a podcast on a certain topic I would see
some blowback on Twitter
you know it would give me the sense that
there was some signal that I really had
to respond to now that I'm off Twitter I
recognize that most of that was just
it was totally specious right it was it
was not something I had to respond to
but yet I would then do a cycle of
podcasts responding to that thing that
like taking my foot out of my mouth or
taking someone else's foot out of my
mouth and it became this this
self-perpetuating
uh cycle which
I mean it's you know if you're having
fun great I mean if it's if it's if it's
generative of useful information and and
engagement professionally and and
psychologically great but and and there
you know there was some of that on
Twitter I mean there were people who
I've connected with because because I
just you know one one of us dm'd the
other on Twitter and it was hard to see
how that was going to happen otherwise
but
it was largely just a machine for
manufacturing unnecessary controversy do
you think it's possible to avoid the
drug of that so now that you've achieved
the Zen state is it possible for
somebody like you to use it in a way
that doesn't pull you into the whirlpool
and so anytime there's a tax you just I
mean that's how I tried to use it yeah
but it's not the way I wanted to use it
it's not the way it it it promises
itself as as they wanted to have debate
I wanted to actually communicate with
people yeah I want I wanted to hear from
the person because
again it's like being in Afghanistan
right it's like there there are the the
Potted cases where it's obviously good
right it's like in Afghanistan the girl
who's getting an education that is just
here that's why we're here that's that's
Obviously good I have those moments on
Twitter where I'm hearing from a smart
person who's detected an error or I made
in my podcast or in a book or they've
just got some great idea about something
that I should spend time on and I would
never have heard from this person in any
other format and now I'm actually in
dialogue with them and it's fantastic
that's the promise of it to actually
talk to people and so I kept getting
lured back into that
um no the the way the same or you know
sanity preserving way of of using it is
is
just as a marketing channel you just put
your stuff out there and you don't look
at what's coming back at you and that's
you know for you know I'm on other
social media platforms
that I don't even touch I mean my team
put post stuff on Facebook and on
Instagram I never even see what's on
there so you don't think it's possible
to see something
and not let it affect your mind no
that's definitely possible but the
question is and I did that for vast
stretches of time right and but then
the the promise of the platform
is dialogue and feedback right so like
so why am I if I know
for whatever reason I'm gonna see like
99 to one awful feedback you know bad
faith feedback malicious feedback some
of it's probably even Bots and I'm not
even aware of who's a person who's a bot
right but I'm just going to stare into
this fun house mirror of
acrimony and dishonesty
um that is going to I mean the the
reason why I got off is
not because I couldn't recalibrate and
and find Equanimity again with all the
the the nastiness that was coming back
at me and not that I couldn't ignore it
for vast rushes of time but
I could see that I kept coming back to
it
hoping that it would be something that I
could use a real tool for communication
and I was noticing
that it was insidiously changing
the way I felt about people both people
I know and people I don't know right
like people I you know mutual friends of
ours who are behaving in certain ways on
Twitter which just seem insane to me uh
and then that became a signal I felt
like I had to take into account somehow
right you're seeing people at their
worst you're both friends and strangers
um and I I felt that it was as much as I
could sort of try to recalibrate for it
I felt that I was losing touch with what
was real information because people are
performing people are faking people are
not who themselves or they're you've
seen people at their worst and so I felt
like all right what's at what's being
advertised to me
here on a not just a daily basis I you
know a hourly basis or you know an
increments sometimes of you know
multiple times an hour I mean I probably
check Twitter
you know at minimum 10 times a day and
maybe I was checking it a hundred times
a day on some days right where things
were really active and I was really
engaged with something
um
what was being delivered into my brain
there was a was
subtly false information about how
dishonest
and
um
you know just generally unethical
totally normal people are capable of
being right it was like it was it is a
fun house mirror it was it was I was
seeing the most grotesque versions of
people who I know right people who I
know I could sit down and at dinner with
and they would never behave this way and
yet they were they were coming at me on
Twitter and I mean it's it's essentially
turning Ordinary People into sociopaths
right it's like people are just
um you know it's and their analogies
that many of us have made it's like it's
like one analogy is road rage right like
people behave in the confines of a car
in ways that they never would if they
didn't have this metal box around them
you know and moving at speed and it's
it's you know all that becomes quite
hilarious and and um
you know obviously dysfunctional when
they're actually have to stop at the
light next to the person they just
flipped off and they realized they
didn't realize they didn't understand
that the person coming out of that car
next to them with cauliflower ear is
someone who they never would have you
know rolled their eyes at in public
because they would have taken one look
at this person realized this this is the
last person you want to fight with
that's one of the heartbreaking things
is to see
see people who I know who I admire who I
know are friends
be everything from snarky to downright
yeah uh mean uh
derisive towards each other it doesn't
make any sense like this this is the
only place where I've seen people I
really admire who have had a calm head
about most things like really be shitty
to other people it's probably the only
place I've seen that and I don't I don't
I tend I choose to maybe believe that
that's not really them there's something
about the system
um like if you go paintballing if you
Jordan Peterson and uh you're gonna
shoot your friends yeah yeah you're
gonna shoot your friends but you kind of
accept that that's kind of what you're
doing in this little game that you're
playing but it's sometimes hard to
remind yourself of that well and I I
think I was guilty of that definitely
um
foreign
you know I don't think there's nothing I
I don't think I ever did anything that I
really feel bad about but yeah it was
always pushing me to the edge of
snidness somehow and
um it's just not healthy it's not it's
not uh
I'm so so the so the reason why I
deleted my Twitter account in the end
was that it was obviously making me a
worse person
and and so
and yeah is there some way to be on
there where he's not making you a worse
person I I'm sure there is but it's
given the nature of the platform and
given what was coming back at me on it
the way to do that is just to basically
users a one-way channel of of
communication just just marketing you
know it's like here here's what I what
I'm paying attention to look at it if
you want to and you just push it out and
then you don't you don't look at what's
coming back at you I put out a call for
questions on Twitter and then actually
quite surprising there's a lot of good I
mean they're they're like even if
they're critical they're like being
thoughtful which is nice I used it that
way too and that was what kept me hooked
but then there's also uh touch balls 69
wrote a question ask what I can't
imagine this part of it but one way to
solve this is uh you know we've got to
get rid of anonymity for this it's like
let me ask the question ask Sam why he
sucks was the question yeah that's good
well yeah one reason why I sucked was
Twitter that was uh and I I've sensed
all that problem so touch ball 69 69
yeah 69 should be happy that I I suck a
little bit less now that I'm off Twitter
I mean I don't have to hear from touch
bowls 69 on the regular the fact that
you have to uh see that
it probably can have a negative effect
just even in moderation just to see that
there is like for me the negative effect
is um slightly losing faith
in the underlying kindness of humanity
yeah that was for me yeah you can also
just reason your way out of it saying
that this is an enemy and this is kind
of fun and it's kind of just the the
[__] show of Twitter it's okay but it
does mentally affect you a little bit
like I don't read too much into that
kind of comment it's like it's just
that's just
uh trolling and it's you know I I get
what's I I get I understand the fun the
person is having on the other side of
that it's like do you though I do well I
do I don't I mean I don't behave that
way but I do and for all I know that
person could be you know 16 years old
right so it's like it could be awesome
for Elon I don't know
okay so the do you think so speaking of
which now that Elon have has taken over
Twitter
uh is there something that he could do
to make this platform better
this Twitter and just social media in
general but because of the aggressive
nature of his Innovation that he's
pushing is there any way to make Twitter
a pleasant place for Sam Harris
I think I'm agnostic as to whether or
not he or anyone could make a social
media platform that really was healthy
so you were just observing yourself week
by week seeing the effect that's on your
mind and on how much you're actually
learning and growing as a person and it
was negative yeah and I also seen the
negativity in other people's lives I
mean it's obvious I mean he's not gonna
he's not going to admit it but I think
it's obviously negative for Elon right
it's just not it's
uh and that was one of the things that
you know he you know when I was looking
into the fun house mirror I was also
seeing that the fun house mirror on his
side of Twitter and it was just even
more exaggerated it's like when I when I
was asking myself why is he spending his
time this way
I then reflected on why why you know why
was I spending my time this way to a
lesser degree right and at a lesser
scale and Adolescent risk frankly right
and so
um
and it was just so it's not just Twitter
it is this isn't part an internet
phenomenon it's like the the whole
Hunter Biden mess that you you um
that was based I mean it was on I was on
somebody's podcast but that was based on
a clip taken from that podcast which was
highly misleading as to the the general
shape of my remarks on that podcast
even you know I I had to then do my own
podcast uh untangling all of that and
admitting that even even in the full
context I was not speaking especially
well and didn't say exactly what I
thought in a way that was would have
been recognizable to anyone you know
even someone with
not functioning by a uh a spirit of
Charity but but the clip was quite
distinct from the podcast itself the
reality is is that we're living in an
environment now where the people are so
lazy and there's their their attention
is so fragmented
that they they only have time for Clips
99 of people will see a clip and we'll
assume
there's no relevant contacts I need to
understand what happened in that clip
right and
obviously the people who make those
clips know that right and they're doing
that doing it quite maliciously and in
this case the person who made that clip
and subsequent clips of other podcasts
was quite maliciously trying to engineer
you know some reputational immolation
for me
um
and
being signal boosted by Elon and other
prominent people who can't take the time
to watch anything other than a clip even
when it's their friend or someone who's
ostensibly their friend in that clip
right so it's a total failure an
understandable failure of ethics
that everyone is so short on time and
they're so [__] lazy that the child
and and we now have these contacts in
which we react so quickly to things
right like Twitter is inviting an
instantaneous reaction to this clip that
it's um
it's just too tempting to just say
something and not know what you're even
commenting on and most of most of the
people who saw that clip
don't understand
what I what I actually think about any
of these issues and the irony is people
are going to find clips from this
conversation that are just as misleading
and they're going to export those and
then people are going to be dunking on
those clips and you know we're all
living and dying by clips now and it's
um
it's dysfunctional so yeah I think it's
possible to create a platform I think we
will keep living on Clips but you know
when I saw that clip of you talking
about children and so on just knowing
that you have a sense of humor you just
went to a dark place in terms of humor
right so like I didn't even bother and
then I knew that the way Clips work is
that people will use it for virality's
sake but the giving giving a person
benefit of the doubt that's not even the
right term it's not like I was it was
really like interpreting it
in the Google is your past the truth is
you even need like I even give
Trump the benefit of the doubt when I
see a clip of trump I mean so because
there are famous clips of trump that are
very misleading as to what he was saying
in context and I've been honest about
that like the whole you know there were
good people on both sides Scandal around
the his remarks after Charlottesville
the clip that got exported and got
promoted by everyone uh you know left of
center from Biden on down you know the
New York Times CNN there's nobody that
I'm aware of
who has
honestly uh you know apologized for what
they did with that clip that he did not
say what he seemed to be saying In that
clip about the Nazis at Charlottesville
right and I've always been very clear
about that uh so it's just you know I I
even even people who I think
should be marginalized and people who
who
um
who should be defenestrated because they
really are terrible people who are doing
dangerous things and for bad reasons
I think we should be honest about what
they actually meant in context right and
and this this goes to anyone else we
might talk about you know who who's more
where the where the case is much more
confusing but yeah so
everyone's care it's just so direct and
then I'm sure we're gonna get to AI but
you know the prospect of being able to
manufacture Clips with AI and deep fakes
and that where it's going to be hard for
most people most of the time to even
figure out that the the whether they're
in the presence of something real
um you know forget about being divorced
from Context there was no context uh
I mean that is that's an a
misinformation apocalypse that is we are
right on the cusp of and you know it's
it's terrifying